son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
diciendo nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
la fiscalía de Colombia suspendió las
órdenes de captura de 17 integrantes de
la guerrilla del eln previo al inicio de
los diálogos con el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro los equipos negociadores Ya están
listos para las conversaciones que se
retomarán la próxima semana en Caracas
tenemos análisis
el presidente de Ucrania bolodimir
selenski informó que más de 10 millones
de ciudadanos se encuentran sin servicio
de Electricidad como resultado de los
continuos bombardeos rusos contra
infraestructura crítica En diversas
regiones del país esto al tiempo que el
gobierno de kiev confirmó que el acuerdo
de exportación de granos con Rusia se
renovará y estará vigente otros 4 meses
a cadena perpetua en ausencia fueron
condenados tres hombres indicados de ser
los responsables del derribo de un avión
de malilla Airlines que sobrevolaba
territorio ucraniano esto en 2014 el
hecho dejó 298 personas fallecidas la
pena impuesta por un tribunal de los
Países Bajos fue calificada por los
familiares como ejemplar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en Colombia donde la
fiscalía suspendió las órdenes de
captura y extradición de 17 integrantes
de la guerrilla del lln esto Solo un día
después de que el presidente Gustavo
Petro confirmara que otti Patiño ex
combatiente de la extinta guerrilla del
m-19 a la que Petro también perteneció
será el líder del equipo negociador del
gobierno en las conversaciones que se
llevarán a cabo con esa organización
desde la próxima semana para analizar
esta información conectamos con Camilo
González pozo el ex presidente del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz Bienvenido a France 24
Cómo recibe el país la noticia de otro y
Patiño como jefe de la delegación del
gobierno es una figura que genera
confianza
Disculpa estamos teniendo fallos para
escucharlo Gracias
fue Constituyente aparte de que
participó en todo el proceso de
negociaciones que condujo a la paz en el
año
1990 con el m-19 en eso Tiene una gran
experiencia es una persona de altísimo
nivel y de capacidad estratégica yo creo
que ha sido conocido por esas virtudes y
va a conducir además que es muy cercano
al presidente eso era un mensaje a los
interlocutores al Ln de dar confianza de
que una persona que es digamos desde el
entraña misma de la historia del propio
presidente de la república esté en la
mesa de negociaciones Bueno hablemos de
la otra parte en la negociación el medio
colombiano cambio aseguraba que de los
16 negociadores que tiene lln solo hay
seis personas conocidas Quiénes son los
otros integrantes y cuál es su
importancia
pues mire Pero si son menos conocidos
pero son personas de la dirección de de
del Ln y que tienen además
experiencias algunos de ellos con
formación académica y con experiencias
reconocimiento en los frentes
importantes del Ln Pero entonces de eso
se trata de que tengan
representatividad y que puedan formar un
equipo para que
actúen de manera coherente y creo que
pues es eso autonomía en la escogencia
de ese equipo
encabezado por días después de personas
y de la máxima dirección del Ln qué
tanto apoyo tienen estas negociaciones
dentro del país con el antecedente de
los diálogos de paz de la Habana que
lograron la desmovilización de las
antiguas FARC y la polarización que vive
Colombia
digamos que ahí hay una expectativa
hay como un cierto escepticismo pero a
mí mismo tiempo mucha esperanza no el
país está cansado de guerras
hay una decisión de la inmensa mayoría
de los colombianos yo me atrevería a
decir que si el presidente tiene 65% de
favorabilidad más del 75% de la opinión
nacional está de acuerdo con que se
exploren y se avance en este camino de
negociación y se llegue a lo que se ha
llamado la paz Total no solamente por
acuerdo con el Ln y otros grupos armados
sino por el pasar definitivamente el
posconflicto cerrar este capítulo de
décadas de guerras en nuestro país pues
señor González a usted muchas gracias
por su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en francés 24
Bueno un gran saludo para ustedes
continuamos en Colombia porque medios
nacionales informaron que la fiscalía
identificó a otras cuatro personas que
estarían involucradas en el asesinato
del fiscal paraguayo Marcelo pechi la
noticia se conoce Solo un día después de
que Estados Unidos ofreciera una
recompensa de hasta 5 millones de
dólares por información sobre el crimen
la familia del fallecido fiscal valoró
esta decisión de Washington y asegurado
que confían en que permita encaminar Las
investigaciones hacia una resolución
favorable
el presidente de Cuba Miguel Díaz
canelli inicio en Argelia una gira
internacional que También incluye
visitas a Turquía Rusia y china en esta
primera jornada el presidente de Argelia
del Madrid
decidió Cancelar todos los intereses
pendientes de la deuda de Cuba y aplazar
su reembolso hasta nuevo aviso el lidera
argelino también ofreció una central
eléctrica solar para paliar los
continuos apagones en la isla
en Ucrania el presidente voló
dimirselenski denunció a nivel
internacional que más de 10 millones de
ciudadanos se encuentran sin servicio de
electricidad en medio de bajas
temperaturas por el avanzado otoño
boreal todo esto ha causado de los
incesantes bombardeos de Rusia que
tienen como objetivo la infraestructura
crítica del país
las consecuencias de otro ataque con
misiles contra Ucrania continúan todo el
día nuevamente ha habido cortes de
energía de emergencia además de los
planeados a partir de ahora más de 10
millones de ucranianos están sin
electricidad
después de La retirada rusa de gerson la
ciudad y sus alrededores vuelven poco a
poco a la normalidad tras ocho meses de
ocupación por parte de las fuerzas rusas
han salido a la luz varios cientos de
denuncias por lo que quieras considera
crímenes de guerra más detalles en el
siguiente informe
garzón tiene una sensación de libertad
desde La retirada de las tropas rusas
los 8 meses de ocupación dejaron a una
ciudad desangrada pero los habitantes
van encontrando poco a poco su
orientación y sus costumbres
[Música]
como aquí en la plaza principal donde se
ha instalado un puesto de teléfonos
móviles para los residentes
las tarjetas sí me eran rusas he
intentado todo este tiempo no usarlas
estas tarjetas son ucranianas Esta es la
señal de nuestra Victoria estamos
liberados Gloria Ucrania y a sus Héroes
los militares son vistos como Héroes a
pocos metros este soldado está
repartiendo autógrafos y haciéndose
fotos con los civiles pero por ahora no
se debería cantar Victoria incluso
siendo la retoma de gerson un tema de
Gran importancia para las fuerzas
defensoras
nuestra única opción es hacerlos
retroceder aún más por seguirlos hasta
el final
con la liberación de garzón y sus
alrededores ya se están denunciando
numerosos casos de tortura Durante los
meses de ocupación los prisioneros
fueron supuestamente atados golpeados o
electrocutados por los rusos
identificaron una docena de centros de
detención en los distritos de gerson los
ciudadanos fueron detenidos ilegalmente
allí los civiles fueron tomados como
Rehenes por los rusos la tortura se
llevó a cabo en cuatro lugares que
actualmente están siendo examinados por
los investigadores
en este sentido se han abierto más de
430 expedientes en esta región los
ucranianos afirman tener elementos que
podrían ser calificados como crímenes de
guerra el acuerdo de exportación de
granos que se logró entre Ucrania y
Rusia con la mediación de Naciones
Unidas y Turquía pudo ser prorrogado el
pacto expiraba el 19 de noviembre pero
ahora estará en vigor durante cuatro
meses más el acuerdo es considerado un
punto clave para mitigar la crisis
alimentaria global que ha causado la
guerra en Ucrania
el acuerdo que busca aliviar la escasez
mundial fue prorrogado por otros 120
días aunque la ONU y Ucrania pedían que
fuera por un año kiev podrá continuar
con la exportación de sus granos por el
mar Muerto
profundamente saber que en Estambul
Turquía Ucrania Rusia y la ONU llegaron
a un acuerdo para la renovación de la
iniciativa de granos del mar Negro lo
que permite la libre exportación de
granos ucranianos
quiero expresar mi profundo compromiso y
el compromiso de la ONU de hacer todo lo
posible para la implementación sin
problemas de estos acuerdos en Estambul
el acuerdo alcanzado en julio permitía
la reanudación de las exportaciones
desde tres puertos de Ucrania un
importante productor de cereales y
oleaginosas con las que puede producirse
aceite vegetal
Moscú también se verá beneficiado del
acuerdo
sí por supuesto una garantía de la ONU
de que se finalizará el trabajo para
garantizar la exportación de alimentos y
fertilizantes rusos notamos que el
trabajo de las Naciones Unidas ha dado
resultados una declaración conjunta de
los Estados Unidos Gran Bretaña y la
Unión Europea sobre la eliminación del
régimen de sanciones para los
exportadores de productos alimenticios y
fertilizantes rusos
Este es un movimiento importante y
positivo y este trabajo finalizará
eliminando todos los problemas directos
e indirectos de esta manera desde julio
se han enviado unos 11,1 millones de
toneladas de productos agrícolas en el
marco del acuerdo sobre cereales
incluidos 4,5 millones de toneladas de
maíz y 3,2 millones de toneladas de
trigo el presidente Turco recepto allí
verduán un actor clave en las
negociaciones propuso que el grano ruso
podría transformarse en harina en
Turquía para enviarlo posteriormente a
África y así aliviar la escasez de
productos en este continente
un tribunal de los Países Bajos condenó
a cadena perpetua a tres hombres
acusados de ser los principales
responsables del derribo del Boeing 77
de la aerolínea malision Airlines en
2014 cuando sobrevolaba territorio
ucraniano en su ruta desde amsterdam a
cual aunque los acusados están prófugos
de la justicia las familias de las
víctimas se mostraron alentadas por la
pena ejemplar y el desarrollo de la
investigación
una victoria agridulce un tribunal
neerlandés condenó a tres hombres dos
rusos y un ucraniano a cadena perpetua
luego de ser acusados de haber
desempañado un papel clave en el derribo
del vuelo mh17 de malicia Airlines el 17
de julio de 2014 en territorio ucraniano
el cual dejó un saldo de 298 muertos
el tribunal califica los hechos que se
consideran probados como conspiración
para derribar deliberada e ilegalmente
un avión que se sabía llevaba civiles
los acusados fueron responsables autoría
de múltiples cargos de asesinatos
durante el juicio un cuarto sospechoso
fue absuelto sin embargo es poco
probable que los condenados cumplan sus
penas ya que están prófugos de la
justicia el proceso judicial fue
realizado en Países Bajos ya que el
Boeing 777 despegó desde amsterdam en su
ruta hacia cuallunpuro investigadores de
distintas nacionalidades examinaron
registros de teléfonos móviles redes
sociales y los restos del avión entre
los cuales encontraron una esquirla en
el cuerpo de una víctima que reveló el
tipo y el modelo del arma utilizada
según el tribunal esto significa que la
participación rusa es Clara
muchos de los familiares de las víctimas
de todo el mundo se desplazaron a
amsterdam para asistir al veredicto del
tribunal
todo el mundo se sintió aliviado
me siento aliviada siento que el proceso
ha llegado a su fin y ha sido muy justo
meticuloso completo y se ha sopesado la
evidencia y siento que ahí está la
verdad
Moscú ha negado desde 2014 cualquier
participación o responsabilidad en el
derribo del mh17 los acusados fueron
juzgados sin asistir al juicio y solo
uno se declaró inocente a través de los
abogados que contrató para que los
representaran
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América a ustedes Les
agradecemos que nos hayan acompañado y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ella llega a Marina sardina con toda
la información de medio oriente en
Expreso de oriente feliz noche para
todos
[Música]